it's not without irony that a discussion
of the American Dream was scheduled for
Riverside sociology student Blas Morales
the week of Donald Trump's inauguration
the president has announced his plans to
cancel the scholarship program which has
protected the 19 year old so far from
deportation like most so-called dreamers
Blas came to the u.s. from Mexico when
he was very young together with his
parents his details are stored with the
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
I see II might be the first ones to be
affected by by under Trump
administration because they have our
addresses they have our phone numbers
they know where we live they know what
to get us an estimated 11 million people
in the US are undocumented most of them
live in California to prevent families
from being torn apart an increasing
number of unauthorized immigrants have
been seeking free legal help at the
nonprofit el riccati in Los Angeles if
you don't have legal representation then
you only have a chance of 10 to 20
percent of winning a cool case but with
the help of an immigration attorney or
representation through organizations
like Elvis Cartier your chance has
almost doubled
Donald Trump has threatened to freeze
federal funds if California lawmakers
failed to comply with deportation orders
lawmakers are preparing for a long fight
produce a large percentage of the jobs
in the United States where the one of
the economic engine
so to hurt us means you hurt the rest of
the country so it'd be very foolish to
do that
there's a good chance California will be
the first sanctuary state the Democrats
have the majority of the votes there and
are determined to protect the state's
immigrant community this activism has
energized blasts he plans on continuing
his studies at UCLA next semester